[تصفيق]
وزير حتى متى
اذهب واختبر نفسك لتكون ممتعًا
مع اليمين المتطرف
[موسيقى]
عندما نفجر الجمر
يمكن المتحمسين العواقب
أصبح دراماتيكيًا في 19 مارس
وزير لاعب الرجبي
كان فريديريكو مارتين أرامبورو
اغتيل في قلب باريس على يد
لقد كنت نشطاء اليمين المتطرف
هادئ
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الأسبوع الماضي هم
الملكيين من الإجراءات الفرنسية الذين لديهم
غزا مبنى بلدية Stains
من جهتك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مجموعات العضلات
الناتجة عن انحلال الجيل
أظهرنا الهوية في رين ليون
وباريس أصدقاء أقصى اليمين في
دفع في صمت الكاتب
الجزء الخاص بك وزير
[موسيقى]
ويقول فرنسا إنها فرنسا إذا
تريد أن تفعل الإسلاموية الثوم
أنت غير مرحب بها هنا
تفعل هذه الخطوات
خطيرة بينما عنف
اليمين المتطرف يتكاثر في كل مكان
في البلاد